Is this a super depressing ending to this course,
and can't we decide anything?
Well, of course, Rice's Theorem and undecidability in general
is prone to a certain criticism.
I mean a crucial thing to notice is that
Rice Theorem means that there is no algorithm
that can decide a functional property for any program that we through at it,
but this is a very general case.
Rice's theorem an also the halting problem, of course,
can only concern this very general case.
If you're trying to prove something about a program you know very well,
you might be in a very different situation,
so if you're trying to find out, for example
if a program you wrote even halts,
and you can't prove that
or can't even show that,
then maybe you should consider writing some better understandable code.
But what it does mean is that there's no fully automated software testing
without trade off.
So it means that fully automated testing
basically the dream of a program
and you throw any other program at it,
and it will tell you if it's correct,
if it stops, if it crashes,
and that's the dream that we probably can't fulfill,
but if accept certain trade offs, so for example,
if we accept that the automated testing program
will be right most of the time
or that it only works on special cases,
then we might be in a better situation,
so I would interpret Rice's theorem not as a general negative message,
but rather as a piece of caution
as to what computers can do and can not do.